hi and welcome to episode number 43 of
the weekly Google plop plop on podcast i
am francisco and i'm here with my
colleague mark modèle hey Mark hey
Francis how are you doing today I'm as
always very happy a very happy we have
one of my friends Brandon Phillips CTO a
car wise yeah he's going to come talk to
us about how they use gr pc at core OS
it's a really interesting conversation
yeah specifically about EDD but also it
was like are you using it somewhere else
a very very interesting conversation
really yeah and how they really kind of
made the decision to make that move over
as well yeah cool why yeah yg RPC not
rest why not something else it's very
interesting i I'm sure people will like
it and after that we'll have one
question of the week which is about data
store yeah local testing the datastore
yeah we don't talk that often about
datastore so I like it that we're going
to be mentioned something as basic
brilliance storing data how do you test
storing data and make your test not be
flaky yeah sounds really good but before
we get into that we have our usual cool
things of the week yeah it's being
renamed yeah there's now cool things of
the week absolutely the first one I just
a huge favorite of mine a gentleman by
them if notch or he's gonna finally he
actually has a name yeah markus persson
if you know minecraft at all i've heard
about it yet yeah it's a thing um i just
have to mention it cuz he tweeted today
about google cloud platform he said not
only does everything just work google
cloud also tries to make you save money
five out of five would cloud again yeah
which is a pre amazing tweet I also
really like I went through all the twins
he wrote about the topic he said the
main thing i like about google cloud
it's super duper user friendly so i
think that this is also an invitation
and open invitation for much to come
talk to us yeah notch if you're
listening we would love to have you on
the show please please please come
that'd be awesome and we said there was
cool things of the week so there's a
second one there's a second one um
so this is also kind of cool I am NOT a
net or Windows developer but we have
some new tools available for those
people that are which i think is really
really awesome so those people who are
used to running powershell inside a
windows environment I hear it's kind of
spiffy there's a bunch of g-cloud
command line tools that are available
now for handling like your GCE instances
cloud sequel instances and your cloud
storage buckets so if you want to manage
your windows instances say to your
command line client you can do so which
i think is really really neat and the
other tool that we also have available
is the cloud tools for visual studio now
right now it's pretty simple it's just
basically a Google Cloud Explorer so
again same subset of features compute
engine cloud sequel and cloud storage
you can actually go see in there and be
like okay what pieces do I have what
zones are they in what regions are they
in and you have a nice way of
visualizing it right through your iee
there in visual studio yeah and on top
of that there's also a cloud minute
video cloud minute videos I think we've
never mentioned them but there's like
basically just one minute video yeah
stuff and they teach you how to do
something very specific we have one
about how to install cloud tools for
visual studio so we'll have a bunch of
links from the show notes to all of
those resources so if you are windows
developer and you use net dotnet tools
on google cloud that will be very useful
for you i'm sure and i think that it is
time to go talk to two Brandon Phillips
from caress sounds good to me that's
that so I'm very excited to welcome to
the podcast a friend of mine and CTO of
Korres hi Brandon Brandon Phillips how
are you doing great thanks for having me
yeah it's always a pleasure so I guess
that most people know what Korres is but
could you tell us what caressed us and
what do you do I chorus sure so chorus
is a company that's building a bunch of
distributed system software and people
have probably heard of us for a few
different products Quade io is our
container registry core OS Linux kind of
the namesake of the company is a
operating system for running containers
and tectonic is a distribution of cooper
Nettie's cool and good you tell
a little bit about what do you do caress
yeah so my role at Carlos is CTO so we
started the company with kind of the
vision of how do we rebuild
infrastructure software and make it
easier to work with and easier to secure
infrastructure software and that sort of
thing and so been kind of pursuing that
mission as software engineer as as
architect as as open source leader that
sort of thing for the last three years
awesome well so I know that core OS has
a very popular definitely here at Google
products cold at CD if you just a little
about what that is and what it's used
for and where people use it sure so at
CD is a consensus key value store for a
lot of folks that is a large mouth full
of words really what it means is is that
a set of machines inside of a data
center let's say you have five machines
are able to store data they will do it
consistently and if one of those
machines dies or gets loses power or
whatever the key values that were stored
there are in the exact same state
replicated in the exact same way on the
other machines and this is really
important because you want to start to
do things when you have lots of when you
have lots of machines you want to make a
decision you want to ensure that
decision is replicated and consistent
across all the machines say you want to
take a lock or you want to update some
load balancer configuration or you want
to update some dns configuration you
want to ensure that there's only one
true configuration of the cluster
particularly as you scale up to lots of
machines and inside of your
infrastructure cool so I have an extra
question about hcv which is what does it
mean sure so we were trying to be really
cute with the name so the idea is that
you hold on to really important cluster
configuration but it's a daemon it's
like a system service and so / etsy on a
single machine like ET c is where you
hold on configuration of a single host
but in the case of a daemon you're going
to want to hold on to that same data so
it's etsy gaiman x yeah that makes sense
cool yeah product marketing was in a
strong suit of Korra
so it was there for people and since and
since coming from me it will seem less
biased what language is at CD written
and STD is written in golf nice yeah
that's actually how I heard about it to
be for the first time and then some time
ago I saw a talk where you explain how
at city was moving from rest to grp see
yes so at TD when we started to build at
CD one of the goals we had three goals
one of the goals was we wanted to make
3d systems easy to consume and that goal
was achieved by using rest we want to
make it so that it was a runtime
reconfigurable so it fits into these
cloud environments so you can add and
remove members from the cluster and that
sort of thing and then we wanted to
build it using like modern technologies
and modern languages like go and so we
started with rest as like an easy to
consume in point but as at CD started
gets adopted by projects like Cooper
Nettie's which have larger and larger
scaling requirements the rest decision
ended up becoming a bottleneck it
started to show up as one of the factors
and in the scaling and performance of
Etsy d and so we started look around at
various solutions and grp was was open
sourced about 18 months ago at least
when we started to look at it and so
we'd already started using protobuf as
the internal protocol and kind of
layering on HTTP to and protobuf on the
client protocol as an option was pretty
compelling in order to flatten out those
that kind of growth and memory and CPU
consumption that we were seeing as we're
trying to scale at CD up to you know
Cooper Nettie's a large crew benetti's
workloads so that's interesting what
sort of like a sort of scaling or
performance increases were you able to
see moving over to do pc yeah so we saw
several several like 10 let's see
there's like 225 x on memory and cpu
improvements by move by moving over and
really it just comes down to
etsy D has a lot of complex data
structures that kitten coded to JSON and
so just simply moving to a format that's
more efficient like protobuf causes just
less a less chatter on the wire it last
bites when you're trying to encode it
and that sort of thing so it's really a
pretty straightforward understandable
how we got there with the improvements
and then HTTP HTTP two we were able to
see really a big a big like concern in
these databases is file descriptors so
as you get more and more users of your
database which is great there's natural
constraints of an operating system and
one of those things as file descriptors
and so being able to multiplex lots and
lots of requests from a single client
onto a single TCP stream was a nice win
on actually the instead of the CPU
memory side the operating system
networking side of the system cool and
is this is this available now in at CD
or is this something that's coming in a
future version what's the timeline there
yeah so at CD v3 which was released
about three months ago introduced the v3
API which is accessible as both a REST
API and as a GOP capi so it's available
today it's being used in a lot of
projects we did upstream work in cooper
Nettie's to enable v3 usage and then
because gr pc has all these great
language bindings we're actually
starting to see things like a java
client come out for at CD v3 and a bunch
of other clients that kind of got built
automatically so it's been a nice nice
adoption curve over the last two or
three months as we released at CD v3
cool so you mentioned that the v3 API is
both in grp c n rest how do you manage
that yeah so the the way that we do that
is there's a really great project that
is called the grp seek gateway and the
cool thing about grp see is that it's
very declarative and it declares
essentially
you know the verb the down the nouns
like what we're actually operating on
and you're able to using this gr PC
gateway library you're able to flatten
that down into a rest endpoint so you're
able to say well this this function call
that I'm going to have in grp see it's
acting on this resource and I want to
map this function call to put or post on
this resource and the resource name ends
up becoming arguments or the resource
path ends up becoming arguments to the
function call and so you're able to
flatten very nicely grp see and to rest
and so this gateway what it does is it
it will expose not just a rest endpoint
that maps to GOP CLA but also an open
API which was previously known as
swagger but it'll it will give you a
swagger document so you can consume it
in a variety of languages that already
know how to speak to swagger enable
dressed in points so it's a quite
powerful little framework if you want to
start building you know internet
accessible api's you get all the best of
the world rest availability and then the
efficiencies and memory efficiencies of
grp see for clients that care highly
about that so I'm curious it sounds like
using geo pc and rest for like a
external so like API calls from external
parties does it use it for like internal
communications as well between like Etsy
d client at City servers yes so inside
of at CD we before we even started to
look at grp see we had already moved to
a streaming streaming protocol based
protocol internally so essentially it's
already HTTP plus protobuf on the wire
as the as the content type and so since
the sed machines there's only like five
or seven of them in a cluster
essentially as maximum we're able to
stream really efficiently with single
HTV connections internally and already
using protobuf so we sort of have a
pseudo gr pc protocol internally and we
haven't really had a need to redesign
that because of the streaming nature of
how how that CD actually does its work
cool is it efficient
expose the rest api through that gateway
does it actually make it much slower is
around the same speed as actually
exposing rest directly yeah so the
there's two considerations the first
consideration is that we do have to do a
little bit of packet sniffing to figure
out is this a HTTP one rest requesters
as an HTTP 2g RPC request that
introduces a tiny bit of latency on the
initial connection but it's a constant
time small latency so we really don't
worry about that and a couple extra
memory copies as far as the efficiency
yeah centrally by using the rest
endpoint you lose a lot of the
efficiencies of the new grp c api so you
go back to including and decoding JSON
and and you lose the ability to say
multiplex multiple streaming requests
over the same socket so you you have
that TLS bring up time and teardown time
so it is quite a bit more efficient I
that same 225 x efficiency by using the
grp CN point ok so at the end of the day
basically you what you do is you expose
a grp see and people that care about
efficiency they will use that one and
you're basically getting rest almost for
free for anyone else that wants to use
swagger open API exactly and when
there's a huge ecosystem around Swagger
and open API and so it's nice to be able
to bridge that world so I know that
consuming in the API that exposes a
swagger definition is very simple and
there's many tools for that what about a
grp capi how do how do you get started
yeah so getting started with this is
pretty straightforward so there are part
about definitions for our grp see
definitions i guess for SCD that explain
all the function calls into the remote
api and then there are various
generators code generators that will
automatically create a client binding so
what we've done in side of SCD was we
have a go client binding and then we
wrap that that generated code into
slightly more nice for humans consume
API and we're doing similar work for
Java but if folks want to build they can
just straight coach in and use the coach
in directly or if they want to kind of
wrap it up we're super eager to help
people make easy to consume and human
human consumable api's for other for
other languages the team's eager to help
did you find you had to do much work
from the generated code to kind of make
it pretty so to speak or yeah that's a
great question so we did a few things so
etsy D has some transactional semantics
so we kind of have like transactions
where it's if if these if the statement
holds true in the database then execute
this transaction if the statement is not
true then do this other thing and you
usually have to do a little bit of
semantic work with closures and etc in
order to like get that to look nice so
people can totally do you know gets and
puts and the basics of a key value store
with the raji RPC client but once you
want to get into like mini transactions
and that sort of thing you want to have
something that saves you from some of
the boilerplate annoyances I kind of
want to ask about the streaming API are
you using it yes so we have etsy dv3 as
a couple of streaming endpoints the most
the most used one of the biggest use
cases of Etsy d is to actually get a
change essentially stream of changes of
all the keys and values so let's talk
through say how Cooper Nettie's uses
this so Cooper Nettie's uses STD is this
primary data store a bunch of different
things are happening say service
discovery information is changing
resources are getting updated through
the rest api and you have all these
things that may be cashing that data and
want to be invalidated when the cash
when when something changes and so by
keeping this TCP connection open you can
create these really dynamic systems
based on etsy dware key changes and then
everyone who cares about that key chain
is immediately notified without any
polling and be the internal protocol
that CD allows for this via kind of in a
safe operation you can kind of think of
Etsy d as being like svn for your key
value stores so if you remember like svn
like the revision system every time you
made a change it increment it the
revision by one and so etsy d keeps is
similar index or revision internally and
so you say i want all things that have
happened since revision x and then it
streams you back all that and then once
you get to the end of the stream it just
keeps the stream open and it'll send you
the next stream from you know x plus in
wherever you left off so that's really
interesting um so what did you do before
GOP see how did you stream that data
yeah so this is one of the biggest
inefficiencies of that CD with the rest
in point was that we use rests long
polling so you would say I want
everything that's happened since X and
you would make a HTTP connection and
we'd stream everything back since X and
then close the connection and then if
you said X and X hasn't happened yet
this revision hadn't happened yet it's
in the future we would just not return
on HTTP body and then once X incremented
then we would return you the HD body
with all the changes and then close the
connection again and so this is very
inefficient way of doing it but it's
essentially how the entire internet
works today is is extremely inefficient
constantly closing HTP request okay that
sounds that sounds really interesting so
I'm wondering why did you choose grp see
for hcv if it was because you had used
it for something else before or it was
just because it was faster and are you
using it now for other things yes so we
ended up choosing grp see for
essentially two reasons one is that we
are interested in HTTP to already
because of this long polling thing we're
pretty dissatisfied but with tearing
down these connections these TLS
connections every time and then we'd
already had experiencing using protobuf
internally at CD or
super comfortable with the tooling and
so gr pc was a pretty natural fit
there's also some legacy reasons core OS
was a very very early user of Google App
Engine and we essentially had built gr
pc based on a bunch of internal stuff
from Google App Engine once we had to
move up with Google App Engine and so we
were really comfortable with this rest
proxy model of grp see gateway and
protobuf from you know our experience
almost three years ago so it was
essentially comfort with the tooling and
confidence in the tooling that cost us
to choose grp see over a lot of the
alternatives that are out there today
and then the other big reason was we
wanted to do this code gen stuff and we
saw that gr pc was building a really
solid ecosystem of client binding
generation tools and we wanted to see if
we could plug into that and that's
that's starting like i said earlier to
come to fruition cool and get to
offensive scaly a question are you using
it for any other projects or do you plan
on using it for other projects yes so we
use GOP see in a couple of different
projects rocket is a container engine
that we built and have started to work
with a bunch of other folks on since
then and rocket has an API service that
exposes a bunch of information on the
host so this is stuff like what images
are available for running what are the
current statuses of the containers
running on the host that sort of thing
and so we use grp see in that service
and this is how one of the components
that we plug into communities where we
plug rocket into kuber Nettie's so
goober daddy's is using g RPC to talk to
rocket today and then all of the
internal customer billing systems for
tectonic calm is all based on grp see as
soon as we've started to use grp see in
our open source projects a lot of our
back office stuff nobody wanted to build
another REST API so it started to be
adopted pretty naturally on all of our
back office work too nice that that
really sounds like maybe we should have
you back for a different episode and
have you talked about all of those
different products that's those sounds
really cool too cool yeah but happy do
it
so I have one more question which is
okay so if you did the how these said
the word the migration from rest to grp
see is there anything any lessons that
you learned that you would like to share
any any painful story or success story
so I think probably the most painful
thing was we pretty rapidly learned by
building a key-value database that
people wanted to store an area data and
binary data is really really hard to
store an arrest API particularly a
key-value REST API because keys are
really hard to represent you end up
base64 ting everything and then the
values you end up having to somehow
generally basics before something worse
into JSON bodies and so grp see because
it has like I made a bite type and could
be encoded into proto buffs has been a
pretty big win there and then just I
think people underestimate the cost of
JSON and a lot of their systems I always
joke that the heat death of the universe
will be caused by like the last JSON
being decoded just because it's so is so
expensive to encode and decode JSON
there are tricks that you can do to make
it more efficient but it does take a lot
of CPU memory to do it and if you're
doing it a lot you need to like consider
consider if there's more effective ways
of doing it yeah cool um well is we sort
of running out of time just a little bit
but um is there anything that we haven't
mentioned or maybe you want to plug or
or shout out to or anything like that
anything we might have missed no i mean
the the main shoutouts i'd like to give
is EDD in rocket if you want to play
around with grp see they're open source
projects if you go to chorus com watch
community he and find out on IRC
channels and mailing lists how to get
involved and then besides that we have a
couple of upcoming events so core OS
continues to a bunch of trainings around
q brunette ease if you want to learn
about that stuff it's a chorus calm /
training cool we'll have those links in
the show notes cool absolutely well
thank you so much
for joining us it was a really great
interview I really enjoyed that yeah
thank you so much and thanks for
organizing everything as well great
questions thank you our pleasure it was
a pleasure and a joy to have Brandon on
the podcast today thank so much to him
for joining us it is really good to hear
from people about how they ended up at
the decision to use a particular product
in this case grp see ya and surprising
how how early on they committed to it it
was before 10 wait wait before and I
used it when it was before 10 and no it
was not that easy now it's better I was
gonna say now it's better that's what
the way I was gonna say it yeah huge
improvement act lease oh no it's a huge
endorsement for the tech but why don't
we move on to the question of the week I
think you found a particularly
interesting one yes so this is something
that I had to deal before a couple of
times so imagine that you're writing an
app engine app okay Inco obviously
obviously and and you have some of your
code that access the data store and you
want to test that what it's doing with
the data store is correct okay there's a
couple ways of doing this but it's
actually kind of easy with App Engine
because you basically get this this fake
they distort think that it's running
there but what happens if you're not on
App Engine what if you're using just the
cloud datastore API oh and I might be
using like a gk instance or some yeah
like you're not on pension well before
it was kind of hard to do it you needed
to basically have some way of faking a
server something to that and we fix that
by providing a datastore emulator ooh
yep so it is super simple to use if
you're using any of the any of the
g-cloud SDKs for which are available for
many different languages but basically
you can find like gclub dash Golan
g-cloud ash node and all of those
there's a bunch of environment variables
that you can set in your environment to
make your code point to those instead to
the production production environment oh
very nice and to see which ones they are
it is actually super simple to you just
go and run from g-cloud directly you're
going to have
a command which is for now g-cloud beta
so it's gclub beta emulators datastore
something and you have like you can run
and when you run you start that server
but also and in it and that will give
you a list of variables that you need to
set in your environment I'll very handy
so yeah it is it is very simple and that
will make your test the depend on
datastore much more reliable because
right now if you're doing it over the
network then you're depending on the
network which is not always a good thing
kind of slow and yeah so this is gonna
be much faster and much more reliable
which is always good yay testing perfect
excellent all right that sounds really
good thank you so much France s for
joining me what are you up to are you
running away anytime soon working on any
sort of fancy content I'm working on
more content for just for Frank I'm
working on two more episodes one of them
people really love go code reviews so
I'm gonna be doing one more and then the
other one I'm still not decided that it
may be also about how to write girl code
yeah lots of fun lots of fun awesome and
after that i'm going to brazil in
November for golfer come Brazil very fun
yep excellent what about you so when
this episode comes out i will have
landed in st. Louis i will be at strange
loop I'm doing couple of things there
they have a pre-conference coding dojo
or I'll be teaching go there glowing
what's the fun with that and then I'm
going to do a game development
show-and-tell unsession which is
basically just like show people games
they are working on nice now that you
mentioned that actually that made me
think that by the time this episode
comes out I will be a github universe
which I think forgot cuz it's not really
trouble because this is a nice girl god
I will be there so if there's anyone
else that wants to talk a little bit
about the cloud or go whatever come say
hi wonderful well again thanks so much
for joining me on another podcast thank
you Mark and talk to you and to you all
next week sounds great CNN
you